how are you doing today sir
i'm good good to see you nice to see you
um i really mean this sincerely i loved
this movie um and i want to thank you
for making it i felt like i was watching
jonathan on screen and it really meant a
lot to me
thank you i saw you a very kind tweet i
really appreciate that
yeah man i i it meant a lot to me um i
have a million questions and not enough
time so i'm gonna hopefully it's gonna
you know i can get through this um you
got to go to the library of congress and
see all of jonathan's
stuff
and i'm just curious i know what
jonathan means to you what was that
actually like and did you like lose your
mind looking through it all
yeah well um on a purely selfish level
like the movie aside it was fascinating
to me as a songwriter to
see his process unfold in his notes and
he's a really different songwriter than
me one of the things he did that i've
never seen another composer do and i've
looked through other people's archives
i've read hammerstein's archives like i
like it at the library of congress um is
he would ask himself questions and that
was often the inspiration for some of
his most enduring songs the most famous
example is how do you measure a year and
there is a piece of paper at library
congress where it's like 52 weeks 365
days then he gets to 525
600 minutes and there's just a bunch of
circles around it
um but
often
he would he would write these questions
and then write the song to answer the
question he was asking himself
and i think it's so fitting that the
last song in tiktik boom is every lyric
is a different question because that's
exactly where he was in his life he was
questioning whether he wanted to do this
for a living he was questioning how he
would get back up from the ashes of
superbia and write the next one um and
and
is a self-portrait of an artist at a
crossroads um and and it's all there in
his notes and it's all there in his
music
if you had the opportunity to show
jonathan a scene from this movie which
one would you want to show him first
oh my god um that's a really great and
tough question i think it's a tie
probably between um
it's a three-way time between the
opening number um where he would get
glimpses of the moon dance and his
apartment and um his loved ones um and
the sunday sequence uh
he only ever heard sunday with him at
the piano and maybe roger bart singing
back up in the background and um i
really tried to build the chorus of his
dreams for that sequence that was my
thesis going into that number um and
then probably therapy um he'd be annoyed
that i cut into it um
and didn't let it just play unfinished
but i i think the turn at the end of
that scene um i think would surprise him
i i think you would enjoy it
i love talking about the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together um as this being your first
feature
what really surprised you about the
editing process that perhaps you weren't
expecting
um first of all i had two amazing
editors and it happened very organically
um
first andy weiss bloom
who is wes anderson's guy and darren
aronofsky guy and um
we were so coveted delayed um by the
time we got through our first screening
cut of this movie darren aronofsky came
calling and said i i need andy weisblud
back
and so uh andy went off to that project
and i was lucky enough that myron
kerstein who had edited in the heights
uh were free and he came
he came to to continue to investigate
the piece with me and and when i say it
came to like this is covid times they
lived in my house we edited this like in
my in my home and so um it was it was an
amazing period um where my kids just got
to know these editors as uncle andy and
myron and because he'd lived and ate
dinner with us
but also to your question
it was the process the part i knew the
least about going in as a first-time
filmmaker and the part that was most
analogous to what i actually know how to
do which is build a score and build a
theater score for an evening you're
playing with the same things you're
playing with tension and release and
surprise and when do i sit in a moment
and when do i explode a moment and when
do i keep it moving
when is the audience ahead of me um you
know the surprise is sort of the thing
sondheim is always telling every one of
his mentees of like keep surprising us
um that's the most important thing you
can do when you're building a score
and so
it was i found that it was a very
analogous skill set um in terms of how
to pace an evening
did you have an actual like much longer
cut of the movie or was it always around
this running time
um i think my rough cut which is just
everything assembled in order was
probably 220. um it was very important
for me that this is under two hours
the off-broadway version is
90 minutes um and this is uh this is in
we're in power 55 but that being said i
put stuff in that wasn't in the
off-broadway version there is
the swimming sequence which was cut for
on broadway there's play game which you
know is uh it's you know jonathan
writing hippo numbers in the 80s um and
so um i i really wanted to to really
just feel like an evening with jonathan
larson so it was it was really about
keeping that stuff uh really tight i
mean one of the most painful things that
was we did a fully dance choreographed
green green dress
sequence um and you can hear uh andrew
and alex singing it on the closing
credits because i wanted you to at least
have it on your soundtracks um
but you know that's one of the ones
where when jonathan comes back from
wherever he is to watch the movie he's
gonna be like why'd you cut that song
and i'm gonna go well because no story
happens during it so i i had josh henry
singing it out of the radio uh as as
they get it on
and
[Music]
it was
that was a tough cut but it also like
really um supercharged the pace of the
movie
i already have to stop i'm going to say
again thank you so much for making the
film and um seriously i loved it thank
you so much
you